I smelled smoke so we looked out the window and we saw flames coming out of the house.
A couple of brave young boys saved the day for a family trapped in their burning home.
I'm Mara Montalbano for News Views.
And when a neighboring home went up in flames,...
...two kids jumped into action to save some children who are even younger than they are.
I'm just thinking, stay calm, keep your mind straight,...
...stay focused on what you're doing.
Pretty clear thinking for an 11-year-old.
Now, Jeremiah Grimes and his friend ten-year-old Isaiah Francis are being hailed as heroes...
...for running into a burning home and rescuing eight-month-old and one-year-old babies.
When I went inside, all you could see was pitch black smoke everywhere...
...and there's flames and I couldn't see that good.
It's really hot.
It felt like 150 degrees in there.
I found my way outside and I took the two kids to my house.
Firefighters arrived and took it from there,...
...saving two more children and the children's father.
They were all taken to the hospital and are expected to survive.
But as for the quick-thinking kids, they say they're glad they could help.
I'm happy.
As long as everyone's okay, I'm happy.